hello there guys so very recently
some images from mandalore and season
two just
leaked on disney plus credit in the
description for these findings so make
sure you go check that out
anyway so in the first picture here we
actually have a boat in
the ocean this is actually the second
time we have seen
a boat in star wars the first time would
be a boat in attack of the clones that
anakin and padme used on naboo anyway if
we go on to the next picture we can see
mandalorian here
on a boat possibly a transport boat of
some kind
i'm not sure what he's doing here but
i'm excited to see and also of course
baby goto is on the boat just chilling
in his little cradle
and the next picture is actually also
quite exciting we see the razor crest
here
which looks like it's been escorted by
some new republic x-wings
this makes me think it will possibly see
a space battle of some kind
also the picture of mafiden from
entertainment weekly
they were talking about how moth gideon
will command a larger vehicle
possibly this is a star destroyer in
this next picture here
we see grief cargo and cara dune on
narrow
which was one of the main plants we saw
in season one it looks like we'll be
revisiting this planet which is good
and i'm pretty sure season two actually
starts where season one left off
so you know it makes sense we'll be back
on navarro so in the next couple
pictures we have the mandalorian using
this jetpack
which you know it's pretty cool to see
that he's going to be finally using this
jet pack more
which is pretty much an essential item
for being a mandalorian so it's good
that he'll finally use it
so in this next picture here it looks
like we have some scout troopers
using speeder bikes which we did see
very briefly in season one
so it looks like we'll be seeing more of
that in season two and the next couple
pictures here is actually really
intriguing to me
um because the background kind of gives
me an exa goal or
dagobah vibe so i'm wondering is this
yoda's species homeland their home world
would a mandalorian finally take baby
yoda to his homeland
possibly this is the scene where we find
out what baby yoda's name is
but who knows let me know in the comment
section below what you think of these
images
and if you want more commentary videos
like this please leave a like and i'll
see you guys in the next video
[Music]
you